Oh welcome back to another episode of
The Walking Dead don't you just love a
good horror flick for every great movie
you've gotta have great popcorn hey
Gordon I'm really glad you're coming
around what we talked about earlier what
you know doing some more
consumer-friendly recipes no no I don't
give a crap about that what were cooking
comes from a user named Howell bizarre
he writes hey Gordon why don't you show
us how to make some of your radioactive
popcorn Gordon
think about the consequences of that
let's make a bet I bet I can get you to
try some by the end of the episode
that's not happening very well if you
win I'll make whatever you want
next episode mm-hmm but if I win you
have to try a dish of my choosing fine
deal there's literally no way I'm gonna
try any of that I'll find a way after
all we are the wok
this episode of The Walking Dead is
brought to you by Colin arts productions
putting the craft and craft services
first thing you'll need is the right
kind of popcorn so we're gonna go out
into the world and do a bit of shopping
you'll also meet playing popcorn and
it's not like they needs the extra
calories anyways you'll also want Serie
blue coloring butter sugar baking soda
salt and don't forget my favorite pure
vanilla extract
you'll also need a radioactive material
and what better place to get it than
Japan Gordon you can't leave the country
in the middle of Japan maybe known for
its booming cities and majestic temples
but it is also home to a wonderful black
man while games
I enjoyed my time in Japan but after
three weeks paid vacation I figured it
was time to get back and finish the
radioactive popcorn
seriously coordinate I don't think
anybody's gonna want to eat radioactive
popcorn I mean look at this level looks
disgusting so do you but you ever maybe
like dump the air yet now preheat the
oven to 250 degrees and use your
saucepan or as I like to use wok and put
it on medium heat to melt the butter now
pour in some sugar salt and let it boil
for four minutes four minutes I'd like
to talk to you about some regional
demographics that we're talking now the
four minutes is up
okay remove from the heat and add food
coloring and one shot of vanilla extract
yeah all right I like to take a few
extra shots of vanilla
don't use that imitation garbage or else
you won't get your daily dose of alcohol
in that hit the spot
after you stir in some baking soda you
can coat the popcorn I like to pretend
that I'm pouring searing hot oil all
over Dave's face I heard that okay
then pop it in the oven for one human
hour and don't forget to put your
radioactive fish on the bottom rack
now I have to go before get back here
Corden oh yeah well then I said if you
want child support call Dracula Oh
oh hey I gotta get back to the show
later homie ah so arm you can feel the
radiation poisoning the radioactive
popcorn is delicious
but I find it's best to just stick one
booger in a regular batch of popcorn
drei I won't run I told you I'm not
gonna eat the stuff would you eat it
with some rice no not eat it with rice
would you eat it with Vincent Bryce
I will not eat it with Vincent Price
would you eat it in a back of a sweaty
bus filled with hobos
absolutely not too bad see Z's world and
: our productions are not responsible if
you die from eating this recipe so what
are you waiting for
hey this is actually pretty good that's
what I was telling you days looks like
you forgot about our bet now try this
Oh what where the goose [ __ ] thanks for
joining us for another episode of the
watching dead subscribe for more
dangerously good treats if you have an
idea for a recipe leave it in the
comments remember try this at your own
home in your own kitchen